have you always loved writing
i have i grew up with my nose in a book
all the time and i think around third
grade i decided to write my first novel
so i i attempted it then um and so i've
always loved stories i'll back up and
say that but
um writing was something that i sort of
did
in order to convey the stories in my
head right so
yeah and were these like ramona cleary
or like what what kind
of books were that i grew up on nancy
drew oh nice it was my favorite
and then i moved to stephen king so that
was an interesting transition
my parents thought as long as i was
reading i was doing something good for
my brain and so they just let me read
whatever i wanted to
um so stephen king became my my go-to
when i was about 10 or 11. interesting
so you liked
you liked mysteries and solving things
rather than
a prom queen yeah get stood up or
something i mean i'm sure there was
plenty of that
too i definitely read the sweet valley
high series religiously in
in junior high or something but um but
yeah stephen king was kind of the go-to
um from about age 10 on and then any any
sort of mystery i could get my hands on
i would have read that too
what pushed you toward filmmaking that's
a good question don't know um
let's see uh so i grew up in portland
and um when i moved back there after
college i started working at a small
commercial production company and that
was my first exposure really to
any sort of filmed medium
and i
you know as i got to know a lot of the
commercial directors it turned out they
were also all
making short films and trying to make
feature films on the side
uh and so that that was my first kind of
exposure to
just the fact that people even made
films um and that it was
it was something that you could pursue
as a career as well
so you grew up on the pacific northwest
and then you went to school at asu
i did yeah wow so you were done with the
rain or you just wanted to be around
sunshine for a while
exactly no i grew up in the rain 300
days of rain a year and when it came
time to go to college i had a friend
who went to asu the year before i did
and so i thought
that seems pretty nice look at that look
at all that sunshine
right clear sky and yep and did you
study writing there
no i was a psych major ah yeah
yeah and you were planning on doing
something with the psychology degree or
well i like to say that i i think i was
drawn to the psych degree because
um i by the time it by the time i had to
declare a major
i had so many psych classes that it just
made sense
to finish out that degree but really it
was just a good sort of broad liberal
arts education i mean i had to take all
of the
you know the english and sociology and
sort of you know basic stuff that
everyone has to take
um but my electives were always
psychology classes too i always liked
the abnormal psych classes and
even the research uh classes that i had
to take for for psychology where it was
like data analysis
all of that stuff was fun for me yeah
how often would the people around you
discourage you from being a writer
oh um
you know growing up i wasn't discouraged
from being a writer
my parents both totally encouraged
reading and so
writing as an extension of that they
encouraged that as well
um i would say through college
everyone encouraged writing um
it probably wasn't until i moved to la
and
um sort of started you know dipping my
toe into the screenwriting
that that i heard about how hard it
would be and how
you know how challenging it was to
launch a career and sustain a career in
screenwriting
so um i don't know maybe maybe it's just
after after you get sort of exposed to
the realities of making money doing
you know an artistic sort of career that
people get cynical
as a kid they totally encouraged it but
as an adult people are like
do something more stable you know so you
went to school at asu and then you went
back to
oregon and and worked within the film
community there or production companies
yeah i worked at a commercial production
company in portland um
they were doing um all sorts of
commercials what was the most fun for me
though
was helping out with the short films
that the directors were doing on the
side
and then what prompted you to move to la
from oregon
well i'd worked in uh commercials for
a little over a year and i sort of felt
like i had enough exposure to know that
this was something that interested me
um just sort of the entertainment
business in general kind of
had a you know a draw um and i felt like
i
knew enough or i'd seen enough about um
how short films were made that i knew
maybe i could do something in production
i wasn't exactly sure what i wanted to
do but i thought i'll come to la
figure it out when i get there so that's
what i did
did you notice any differences in the
way the industry is approached
being in uh oregon versus in portland
versus la
um yeah hold on yes oh sure
the first thing i noticed actually um
when i worked at that commercial
production company we did have some
business occasionally with uh different
companies in la so i would end up having
to call
various vendors in la to and ask for
things you know order things whatever
and the first thing that i noticed about
the difference between portland
and la is that people in la have no
patience for you on the phone i would
call and i would make small talk like
hey how's it going
how are you today because that's what
you do in portland and um and they'd be
like yeah what do you need
so um that was the big difference that i
noticed uh while i was still in portland
um let's see after moving to la
uh let me think big differences um
yeah i can't it's so far so long ago i'm
not sure i remember any
sure sure that's but that it's an
interesting thing that where you were
trying to just be genuine and then
yes and you saw that that doesn't work
and maybe it's even almost like
seen as like what do they want you know
right it was i think people thought that
i was
i think people that i was talking to
thought that i didn't know what i was
doing
because they were like listen if you if
you knew what you were doing really
you would know that we don't have time
to make small talk just tell me what you
need and i got to get off the phone you
know
sure sure yeah sometimes i know kindness
can be seen
as a weakness here i'd like to think
that that's not but there is occasion
when i have seen that what makes you
great at story
and how did you get good at it my big
education in story was really when i
worked for blake
on his second book just because
the the thing that i had to do in that
role as sort of his research assistant
was
watch 50 movies and not just watch them
once but watch them over and over again
um and you know break them down and sort
of figure out what the structure was and
how they were working right so
so that was like my crash course into
story before that
i worked in the entertainment business i
read scripts i was
you know writing coverage and um talking
about
scripts with people but it wasn't until
i did that and had that sort of like
immersion
into just the rhythm of stories that i
really
i felt like i sort of you know absorbed
it and it was like in my bones after
that
um so that was a great experience and i
think that that
is that was my first um or not my first
but that was
probably the um the biggest impact on
my understanding of story wow that's
really cool so would he give you a list
of movies to to watch
oh yeah so in the second book there are
50 movies that are broken down
um sort of beat by beat and um so i
think overall
we watched more than 50 because you know
50 made the final cut but it was
it was watching the movie once just to
sort of you know
let it wash over you and then it was
watching again paying attention to
structure
and then it was watching again taking
notes and trying to figure out like okay
is this
sort of time wise is this kind of where
the act ends and
is this where it escalates and things
like that and and trying to like really
make sure that we understood it uh so
each of those movies i watched at least
three times
um and that was i think if you if you
want to
um sort of have an understanding of the
rhythm
of storytelling that's a great exercise
just sit in your apartment for several
months watch movies non-stop watch the
same movie over and over again because
you'll
you'll just sort of like absorb it you
know
was there one or two of the films of
those 50 that was really
it was just a little bit difficult to
grasp the structure and some of the
things around it
oh yeah i mean i think crash was a tough
one to break down because it's
it's not traditional right it's um it
has a
three-act structure but because it
follows different story lines
it makes it harder to kind of like
follow that one
through line all the way through right
obviously um but so that was
that was probably one of the harder ones
to just figure out
how were they making this work in a way
that felt like it was all one story
that had sort of a beginning middle and
end yet we were being told this one
story through
three separate story lines or three or
four i can't remember
and then when you would watch these
these different movies i know you said
they were more than 50.
would you write coverage on them no so
um
well i take that back it wasn't coverage
like we think of coverage but i was
writing kind of the
um the structure breakdowns of them like
here's the you know opening image here's
this here's what happens in the setup
here's the inciting incident
all that stuff and how long would would
each like movie
oh probably three pages yeah
yeah a little synopsis of the story yeah
can you tell us how you met lake snyder
oh sure um i
my first job in la was working for a
manager producer as an assistant
and blake was a friend of his and so he
would just come in the office and
uh was such a friendly genuine person
that he of course made time to talk to
me the assistant
uh before he would go in and have a
meeting and so um
i got to know him over time and he was
very supportive
of writers in general and of me being
interested in screenwriting
and so when he wrote his first book he
um gave it to me to sort of beta read
and give him my thoughts and
tell him if it was useful and um and i
think i still have that that caught that
original copy
and then when he decided to write the
second book he asked if i would sort of
come
be his research assistant so then that's
when i started watching all of the
movies for him
wow any any memories anecdotes just from
just seeing how he worked um gosh not
that i can share
no i'm kidding um no he's uh i think the
lasting memory that i have of blake is
just that he was so enthusiastic about
story so
if i ran an idea by him for a script
that i wanted to write
he would instantly you know latch onto
it and get excited
um and you know start pitching ideas and
that enthusiasm i think is what sort of
set him apart because he
you know you could even be sort of
lukewarm about your own idea that his
enthusiasm would make you fall in love
with it and
excited to write it so and did you think
that his books would have such
an impact i mean there's so many great
books out there
but his is like in another stratosphere
in terms of the reach
yeah i i remember reading the first book
and
um and he one of the things that he
wanted to know was do you think this is
useful do you think right
writers will be able to use this and i
remember thinking like this is amazing i
can't i can't imagine anyone not being
able to get something out of this so
i think just the way he sort of
simplified and distilled you know
the same things that we all talk about
with 3x three-act structure
and um you know he really he really took
the idea of three act structure and sort
of made it accessible
um and easy to understand even if you're
just starting to learn about
story structure or screenwriting in
general um so i think that
that is what makes his books
you know lasting and have such a big
impact on people
great yeah i know he even wrote a letter
to david back and was it 2008 or 2009
it was so cool yeah in the
[Music]
yeah it's funny people still people
still
submit log lines to that email address
yeah and does does anyone answer it or
uh usually i do
yeah oh okay yeah cause it's still i
mean it's still going it's it's own
it's kind of like the artist's way it's
gonna always yeah
kind of be in there i mean people love
it it's you know it's controversial
at times right like there's some people
that think it's too formulaic or
whatever i think that those people are
sort of
not are sort of missing the spirit of it
a little bit
um but uh but yeah i mean people
rave about it still that are just
finding it now so
what is story testing uh well the way i
think about story testing
is um sort of asking a few questions of
your story before you
get into writing the draft just to make
sure you have kind of the foundation of
it
and all the pieces working together the
way they should be before you
invest a bunch of time in writing the
pages of that script
can someone call themselves a writer if
they're only writing coverage
wow that's a good question um yeah i
think you can consider yourself
a writer because you're writing coverage
so um
i think that i think people are
writers if they enjoy writing
want to write and do any form of writing
well that was actually my next question
and can someone
or does someone have to love the
screenwriting process to be a great
screenwriter
oh i don't think so i've heard too many
professional
screenwriters uh talk about how painful
it is to birth a story
and to actually make themselves sit down
and write a script you know i
i think you hear people talk about it
sort of across the spectrum some people
love it and can't wait to get lost in
the story can't wait to sit down and
just
you know immerse themselves in whatever
world they're creating
but i think that there are also you know
people on the other end who
um maybe they love stories and they love
filmmaking
they love putting the idea for a film on
on the page
but the process of writing is not always
fun
not always easy right yeah it's funny as
i was just watching
um an old video with the screenwriter of
quiz show and oh
uh the one it's like a new series tommy
i guess it's on cbs
and he used to be like a critic or i
don't know he worked for the washington
post
and he said now you know this is an
older video so
now he's a writer and how hard it was
and how he didn't realize
screenwriting is really difficult and
you know you look at his films
and they're effort you know it seems
like effortless writing but
it it's just interesting to see that so
much goes into
if you change one part then you've got
to go in and change the back and
do you think people realize that when
they when they see these films and they
go oh i can do that
no i think actually if you uh if you
enjoy movies and you
not necessarily you don't necessarily
want to be a screenwriter but you enjoy
movies
um it's useful to try to write a script
because it'll give you even more
appreciation for what's gone into
that movie being made and just the the
you know
all of the writing that had to happen to
create that world
and those characters and that story
before you know
before it even got to your theater so um
i actually think that's a good exercise
for people who love movies
well i have a log line and it's not very
good and i suppose i want to run it by
you and poke holes through it
okay so i just um i'm hoping we can
deconstruct it
it's not very clear and maybe you can
help me clean it up so
a well-meaning librarian helps
a prison writing group falling head over
heels for someone entirely outside of
her circle of friends
and peer group teaching her the meaning
of true love
i know it sounds very cliche but anyway
so it is it's too long
is it too confusing yeah um well i i
don't think it's necessarily too long um
if you need that many words to
convey the story then you need that many
words but um but i will say
the thing that i think is a little bit
confusing about it is it felt like it
jumped from one story to another
um so if i were going to help you
workshop it i would ask you who your
who's your protagonist
uh the librarian she's she's um you know
highly educated came from you know maybe
a liberal world but
more of a privileged world and she works
in this library where they have a
writing group and some of the
individuals there um have
been you know incarcerated and now
they've come out and what are we
watching for sort of the bulk of the
movie are we watching her work with
writers or are we
there was another part to the log line
that i've forgotten now but
was it before she fell in love there was
something else um
i think well-meaning yeah i had said
that so maybe it shows
her life um wanting to be involved in
like community activism and things like
that i thought there was a part about
her
uh going outside of her circle of
friends oh yeah good point um she
she no no this is great she does and so
she has
very she's kind of from this like
literati you know very very like upscale
you know discussing ideas um maybe
college professors and people like that
in her circle of friends
well i think that that part you can
probably leave out of the of the log
line because it sounds like the movie
that you're pitching is actually about
this um
maybe somewhat privileged uh liberal
librarian
well-meaning librarian who is working
with a bunch of incarcerated writers
right so
that's kind of the the main gist of your
movie is that
does that sound right yeah and maybe
she's imprisoned by that world and no
pun intended because
she feels like she's got to still
keep in competition with her peer group
okay
um that may or may not fit in the log
line so
what i usually tell people is that we
want to focus on just the foundation
elements that
that you need to tell your story start
there and then you can sort of like
judge it up to add
add color and detail if you're pitching
it but i would start with the
protagonist the story goal so that main
thing that she's trying to accomplish by
the end of the movie
um the main force of antagonism
or opposition and then some indication
of the stakes is usually helpful right
so that we understand why we should care
about that story so i start with those
four things
and then i will say that there's like a
stealth
fifth element that you can include that
sometimes makes it easier to convey
the the real sort of meat of your story
right so
if um just for example if her story goal
is to um you know
i don't know i think you said something
about when the love of
somebody is that oh she falls in love
with someone that's been incarcerated
and
this individual is way outside of like
her social circle and what she would
consider
in a mate okay and she just can't help
herself
okay if that's not the a story that
might not belong in the log line either
but so i would say that whatever her
story goal is so
whether it's to you know get this
writing group um
published in a national magazine or
whether it's to
um get oh let's go with this one let's
say that her her ultimate story goal is
she starts working with these writers
and her goal is to
get funding to keep this uh program
going because it's going to be
canceled right so if that's her ultimate
story goal just putting that
in the log line doesn't necessarily tell
us what we're watching
over the course of this movie right
which is that's the entertainment value
we want to know like
when we go see this movie what are we in
for so um
so that fifth stealth stealth element
that i was talking about is sometimes
the method
or the strategy that the protagonist is
going to use to achieve that goal
because sometimes that gives us more of
an indication of what's the actual movie
that we're watching right
so if her goal is to save this writing
program
you know saying um a well-meaning
librarian works
or a well-meaning librarian strives to
save
the incarcerated uh prisoners writing
program
at her local prison that doesn't
actually tell us what we're watching
so if you include the method then it's
something like
a well-meaning liberal librarian uh
begins working with incarcerated women
to put their stories on the page um
in order to save the writing program at
their prison
something like that that doesn't really
give us a sense of the opposition or the
conflict but it gives you kind of a
start with some of those story elements
if that makes sense
sure sure i guess um and this is where
i'm not being clear is that
she falls in love it's actually a man
but it could be a woman
that um is not is not
what she thought prince charming would
be and she's been looking for this
prince charming okay
when this individual is right here and
he doesn't
tick all the boxes that she thought okay
so it's more about
her sort of journey as being
in this group she's a librarian she's
sort of an expert in her field
but then she falls head over heels for
someone that
she never expected that she would and it
causes
a backlash for her got it so
interestingly in when you read the log
line i thought that the main thrust of
the story was her work
with or his work with these incarcerated
writers
but the way you're describing it now it
sort of seems like maybe the a story is
really the romance
is it about the relationship okay yeah i
think it's it's her coming out of
her shell and being with someone that
she never thought she could fall in love
okay well so in that case i would
totally change the log line and i would
say it would be
something because this then really
her work with the writers is just the
setup it's just the situation that gets
her
to meet this guy essentially does that
sound right yeah that's it
so um so i would say um after
taking a new position working with
incarcerated writers
a well-meaning but give me another
descriptive word
oh man sheltered yeah sheltered okay
a well-meaning but sheltered librarian
uh falls in love with
uh the most unlikely i don't know um
the most unlikely suitor okay
and pursues a relationship with
him even though he's so far outside of
her social circle
that i don't know something else that
happens in the story so that we get the
sense that it's a romeo and juliet type
of story right where there's like
incompatibility on the on the surface
but they they sort of have
some sort of bond right that that
connects them does that
sound right um so really we get the
sense that in that in that log line we
want to understand that what we're
watching in this movie
is really about this relationship
between these two mismatched people
but the fact that um their their
connection their the strength of their
connection makes this a love story worth
watching basically so that's what we're
trying to get in the log line
right does that make sense it that does
and i just realized it it
this mirrors the movie white castle i
think with susan sarandon and james
spader
oh i don't think i've seen oh it's so
good yeah and so and again where but
it's flip-flopped in that james spader
is the one that's
from more of the privileged um
environment and susan sarandon is like
the single mom that's older and
she's brought to this like party and
everyone just is totally quiet like
and just the tension in the room and
it's so awesome yeah because what we
because the real
main conflict of your story is about the
fact that these two
you know shouldn't have fallen in love
but did right and so it's about them
trying to make their relationship work
despite all of their differences and the
unlikeliness of their relationship is
that
yeah that's it yeah so that's what we
want to get in the log line so then
if i were to clean it up because mine is
a mess and it's all over the place just
um a well-meaning librarian
teaches a prison writing well so i would
probably start with the fact that she
has that position
teaching prisoners um because that's
that's really just the setup you just
want to get that sort of like this is
the situation that gets her into this
bigger situation which is the what the
movie is about right so
i would probably start with um after
taking a position teaching incarcerated
writers
a well-meaning but sheltered librarian
uh forms an unlikely relationship with a
guy from the wrong side of the tracks or
however you want to characterize him
i don't know if he's like the if he's
another prisoner or prison warden or
whatever he's done he's done his time
and he's out
and um he's he's done what he thinks to
make amends
okay so i would say forms an unlikely
relationship
with um with a guy
with an ex-con and
um trying to figure out how to
characterize the the nature of that
main conflict which would be and um
you know they they embark on
forms an unlikely connection with a with
an x-con and they embark on
a whirlwind romance that
tests both of their preconceived notions
about
love and the way to live your life or
something like that
okay yeah you'll have to switch out
those elements to to be true to your
story but that's kind of like the
structure of it that i would go for
that's excellent yeah i love it and if
we were to be to come up with a title
for it which i haven't okay um
where would we go with the title to
would it be
someone's name would it just be you know
um
i i don't know that's a good question
and i
i dislike titles i just like coming up
with titles but
uh what i usually tell people is that if
you're writing a spec script
um be more clear than clever in your
title
because i need to be able to hear that
title again and remember
what script that was you know so a good
example
or a good exercise actually is if you
read the
um the titles and the log lines for the
scripts on the blacklist
and then put that list away for a week
and come back to it and just read the
titles see if you can remember
what log lines you know which log lines
went with which titles
if you can't then that's not a useful
title to me as a person who's trying to
remember which scripts i've read and
what that script was about when somebody
wants to
ask me about it you know um does that
make sense
it does so you said clever should be the
last thing
i mean i think cleverness in a title is
great and sometimes that
can make it catchy and that can make it
you know have a sticky
quality that that will help you remember
what that script was
but if it's like for example if you're
writing um a biopic
about seaberg right right just
call it seaburg so that i can remember
when i see that title again i'll
remember exactly what that script was
you know okay
i understand right what what and not try
to do something
you know the the the french temptress or
well she wasn't french but she
ended up living in france yeah yeah okay
yeah
yeah i don't know if that's useful to
you at all but no it is it is
um and do you think with titles the the
um
less is more in terms of words oh i
haven't actually
thought about that directly but um
i mean i guess if you can convey what
your script is about
in fewer words that's probably better i
won't say that's a hard and fast rule
but
that's probably better okay well thank
you for this line by the way
well i will say that in a in a title
though sometimes the sometimes you do
get a a title that's long on purpose and
that's what makes it memorable
you know what i mean right three
billboards out of ebony
right i mean like that nobody's gonna
forget when they see they may not
remember the title
off the top of their heads but when they
see it they will remember what that
movie is so i don't know i guess
there's no there's no hard and fast
rules there no right answers no wrong
answers
what are three mistakes screenwriters
make with log lines
well the three that i tend to see are
um stopping at the setup so
describing just the you know the initial
situation
and not really giving us any indication
of what happens in the the meat
of the movie if that makes sense um
so you know often when we come at
stories
we we come with an interesting what if
and
that's a great you know entry point into
a story but then
you sort of have to develop that that
continuation of
of the conflict right like what's the
real problem that they're trying to
solve
um in a log line if you just give me the
setup i don't know if you've thought
that through
if you've come up with the story part of
your
of your screenplay i know that you've
come up with a situation but not
necessarily a story so
that's the first mistake that i see
people make with log lines
um the second one is um
is not having an act two which is a
little bit different than the first one
uh if you are conveying to me what's
happening in your movie but it's
something
sort of transitory or that can be done
in you know one
scene or one minute then that raises a
little bit of a red flag because
then it feels like maybe you don't have
enough to sustain an entire movie
and then the third mistake that i see a
lot is packing too much detail into your
log line so
you know usually this happens after
somebody has written the script and so
they know
so much about the story and they've
fallen in love with everything that
they've written
that then they try to write they try to
distill all of that down into one
sentence and it's really hard because
they have all these details that they
know and all these
you know subplots and supporting
characters and character arcs and all
these all this stuff
and so um they'll try to jam all of that
into one sentence and then that just
makes it
confusing and we want that log line to
ultimately to just really convey a solid
sense of
what that movie is that we'll be
watching if we sit down in the theater
right
so we need to know like what's that main
conflict that big conflict that we're
going to be
tracking over the course of that movie
and have a sense of the the nature of
the action that we're watching on screen
so what are
what are the you know sort of broad
strokes things that that character is
doing
in pursuit of that story goal um that's
really what you're trying to get
into the log line and like i will say
you can start with those sort of four
foundational elements your protagonist
the story goal the antagonist or main
force of opposition
and the stakes start there write one
sentence with those elements
and that should give you a really good
start for your log line you may need to
add a few details but
that way you're starting with a solid
foundation and then you can
add details as necessary rather than you
know starting
by putting everything you know about the
story into a sentence and then trying to
pull things out
so going back to uh the log line example
that we did and i don't know whether
this video will come out before the
other one
so um people might be confused by what
i'm referring to but
the log line that i gave you was
definitely confusing and there was too
much
in it so we cleaned it up and we found
out that it wasn't just about the
writing group it was more about her
finding love
yeah so that was getting to the meat of
it yeah because
i think if you were gonna if you were
going to write that script it sounded
like what
the story that you wanted to tell was
really about this mismatched romance
right
and so that's what we want to convey in
the log line because then when i read
the script or i watch the movie
that's the movie that i'm getting you're
not you're not telling me um
that uh dangerous minds story you know
you're telling me the the english
patient or whatever and so
those are you know both both movies that
work but
but i want to know which one i'm getting
before i pick up that script or
before i go see that movie so making
sure that you convey a
true sense of the story that you want to
tell in that log line that's
you know that's what we're looking for
what situation will
a screenwriter use log lines when will
this come up
well i think there are a few different
situations um
you know in the classes that i teach we
usually start with log lines as sort of
the first
iteration of your story so just like you
and i were talking about
trying to figure out what's that what's
the story that you actually want to
write um we use log lines as a way to
kind of figure that out like what is
this story that you're trying to tell
um in that case i think that you know
it's we put much more of the focus on
getting those essentials of the story
into the log line so that it's
um we can tell if that foundation is
solid before we start
developing the story further uh but you
might also use a log line in a query
letter
or to pitch to somebody in person um you
know that that elevator pitch of your
story so
if you're using that version of a log
line you're probably going to
think a little bit more carefully about
the language that you use because it's
not just for internal use anymore you're
actually presenting this as
you know this is the product essentially
that i'm trying to pitch you so you'll
probably be a little bit more careful
about word choice
and a little bit more conscious of
getting
really conveying the tone of the story
and sort of that
that feel of the movie if you can
through the word choice and through
um just the language and the way you're
describing the situation
i'm sorry can you explain foundation i
know that's jumping a little bit
oh yeah off topic but no the um when i
talk about the foundation that's just
me referring to kind of those essential
building blocks of your story so the
the protagonist the story goal the
antagonist or
opposition and the stakes like those are
the things that
every story needs you kind of have to
have those elements and so
that's where i start if i'm helping
someone figure out
what you know what story they're telling
or figure out what's not working about
their story
you just have to start with the
foundation layer and then and then work
your way up right so
make sure that that's solid and then we
can talk about the other pieces that go
into making your story work
so what if someone says well i don't
have a really strong antagonist but i
have a great sidekick character
is it because there's no opposition
there's nothing that this hero needs to
overcome
yeah that could be that would be my
first instinct is if someone says
they're writing a story that doesn't
have an antagonist
um i would it wouldn't be necessarily a
you know a deal breaker but i would want
to know where is that conflict coming
from
right because if you are telling a story
where
sort of nothing goes wrong it's probably
going to
be either a pretty short story or we're
just going to get bored pretty quickly
so i would want to know i would question
where is that conflict coming from
if it's not if it's not a sort of you
know
traditional like direct conflict that we
can see between
two people or a person in a group or you
know that type of thing
then then what is making this um
journey for your protagonist so
difficult and
or so interesting you know how does a
screenwriter determine the why
of telling their story i mean do they
need to know exactly why
writing this is important to them
that's a good question i i think that i
would not say
someone has to know why writing their
story is important to them
um only because i feel like that puts so
much pressure on people
and especially beginning writers often
are really
intimidated by trying to say something
profound
or new and unique with their stories so
um i i think maybe a better exercise
is to before you dive into actually
writing something and you get into that
sort of long slog of writing and
rewriting i think a useful exercise is
to get in touch with your
sort of spark of inspiration about an
idea so that might be
why writing this story is so important
to you that could be what inspires you
about it
but it might just be you know i've
always loved mysteries and i want to
write something
that is really twisty and turny and hard
for people to solve and
i think that's enough like that you
don't have to
um not all of us are writing highbrow
type stories you know
i think there's something totally valid
about writing great entertaining stories
and maybe what draws you to that
isn't um isn't something profound or
you know uh contributing something
profound and new thinking to the world
but it's just a desire to entertain
people
okay does that make sense yeah it does
it does so you can
you can do dark waters which i don't
know if you saw that movie
i didn't i heard about it yeah it's
fantastic or you could do something
light and fluffy and each one
is going to have its own audience yeah
and reason for wanting to do it not
everybody wants to go to a dark place
right so people just want to have fun
and keep it light and also i mean i
think that
um if you you know if
if you if you're learning about story
maybe
if you're learning screenwriting maybe
don't put so much pressure on yourself
to write
like your ultimate perfect screenplay
first don't write the
don't write like the the passion project
first maybe
it might be a good exercise to choose a
story that's a little bit more
straightforward that you find
entertaining but not necessarily you
know if i write this this will be my
great american screenplay type of thing
just to learn the mechanics of a
screenplay and how to put a story
together and that can be a good
learning exercise i think um and in that
case you know
the thing that inspires you about that
story might just be like oh i
knew this interesting person once and i
want to put them in a crazy situation so
you know i think we come at stories from
different directions
so maybe save that one that's like that
deep that one that's just
until you really feel like you you've
mastered the craft in some sense or you
know what the rules are so you can kind
of bend them
well i think that um you know i hesitate
to tell people to write something or not
write something because
sometimes that passion is what you need
to get you through the writing right so
if it's
if it's the story that you've been
passionate about your whole life and
you're just now getting
to you know your opportunity to write it
down
then go for it i i'm not going to stop
anyone from writing their passion
project
but um but i do think that um for some
people
the pressure to write like the perfect
screenplay
especially to write that one screenplay
that's going to be
kind of the epitome of everything they
hoped to put into a story you know
i think that's a lot of pressure so um
you know i i think
right with the wind at your back
if somebody really wants to write a
story and it's just like they have to
get it out of them it's consuming them
do they need to know why they they they
want to tell it or or just the fact that
it's consuming them
is enough oh uh yeah i think the fact
that
that it's consuming them i think that's
a great place to start right because you
sort of need that energy and that
passion
to carry you through the writing process
um
i think probably as they write they will
discover
what makes that that particular story
important to them
um a lot of times i think that you know
we can get
uh inspired by an interesting idea for a
story and then
over the course of developing it we can
get in touch with
the meaning behind the story and sort of
what we want to say with it
um or as you might call it the theme of
the story right
so i think it's totally okay to start
working on a story not really knowing
what you're trying to say with it and to
find that over time because
um that will happen like as you get in
touch with who the protagonist is
what their journey is through the story
what transformation
they're going through the effect that
these events are having on them
that will help you get in touch with
what the meaning of the story is
so then someone doesn't really have to
know like where does this fit into my
personal history or how i look at life
it's just if i have this spark in me
that wants to tell it
you think that's enough yeah i think so
because i think that um
you can you know you can comment out a
story a lot of different ways you might
just
want to entertain and that's great i
think that that's a totally valid reason
to write
to write a screenplay right um you may
also have a passion project something
that you've been
fascinated by or that you've been
carrying with you your whole life and
you're finally
getting around to putting it down on
paper and i think that that's a valid
reason to write a story too so
um you know i think maybe key to this is
don't get intimidated by
trying to say something deep and
profound right away
it's okay if you're coming at a story
just because this situation
where this character fascinates you
makes you laugh
you know makes you excited makes you
curious whatever
that's that's a totally valid way to
come at a story um and then
you know if you are worried about um
finding the meaning or finding the
reason behind the story
i think that you will find that as you
develop kind of all of the elements of
the story the protagonist and what
they're going through
and what that the way the story changes
them
will convey the the theme or the meaning
that takeaway message of the story
how should a writer start a screenplay i
think if you want to write a screenplay
you should take the path of least
resistance so start the screenplay
however feels easiest and most fun to
you right
um if you don't know where to start i
think a good place to start is with just
a brain dump so i think
sitting down with whether it's you know
notebook and pen or on your laptop or
whatever
and just writing down everything you
know about the story and it doesn't even
have to be stuff that you know that
happens in the story
it can be things that you like about
this
type of movie so i love horror movies
because they scare the pants off of me
and they make me grab my boyfriend's arm
or whatever it is
you can write all of that stuff down
that's all part of like what you're
going to try to get into your project
right so everything that inspires you
about it maybe
why you want to write it maybe um the
last movie you saw that felt sort of
like you would like your movie to feel
movies that inspire you
and then also in that same document i
would also try to put everything that
you do know about the story so
uh the idea that i have is about this
guy and this is his backstory and these
are his friends and
this is the situation he finds himself
in and i don't know where this goes but
he encounters some sort of swamp monster
and you know
stream of conscious consciousness just
brain dump i think that's the great
place to start your story
for two reasons one because it gets you
um to kind of like download your spark
of inspiration
right which is really useful later on
when you're feeling bored and tired of
your story
you can revisit that document and
remember like what was it
like when i fell in love with this story
and then the second reason is
that you can actually pull a lot of the
sort of elements that you need to start
building your story from that document
so
if you said i know it's about this guy
who you know grew up in texas
that's probably your protagonist right
so that gives you one of your elements
and
you can sort of start circling the
things that you've written down that you
may not have known were
important yet but you can start using
those elements to build your story from
so that's where i that's where i think
everyone should start if they don't
know where to start um start with a
brain dump and is that a natural part
of being close to a screenplay for a
long time is you will get bored and
tired of it but that doesn't mean you
need to abandon it
yeah i think um i i can't
remember if i've ever met a writer who
didn't say
at some point or another they got tired
of the project they were working on
the you know one of the most common
things that i hear people say is i can't
look at the script anymore
so i need a fresh set of eyes on it
right so
um i think it's totally natural totally
common to
be you know because the writing process
is so much longer than you think it's
going to be
usually for the most part every script
that you work on is going to take more
drafts than you
expect um and you know they may not be
full rewrites or full drafts but there's
always
one more thing that oh if i connected
these elements that would
you know give it more meaning or if i
went through and tweaked the dialogue of
this person that would give them more
you know more characterization or
whatever so there's always more to do
um so the writing process is always
longer than you think it's going to be
so i think that yes that's very common
to fall out of love with your project at
some point or another probably multiple
times
and that's why it's really useful to
kind of
crystallize your spark of inspiration at
the very beginning so that you can
revisit it later
you know when you are feeling low about
it and feeling like uh why did i ever
start this you know you can
go back to that initial like true love
feeling
if we take novel writing so we're going
to be spending a lot of detail
on setting a world but if we are doing a
screenplay
are we really how much are we really
paying attention to
like the where the setting of the scenes
is won't some of that be fleshed out
when the actual film starts and the
director
storyboards or whatever yeah um i mean
i think that it is important to pay
attention to the where of your story
right um
because every choice that you make in
your screenplay should be a deliberate
one so if you've chosen a setting
there should have been some reasoning
behind that you're not gonna set
your love story about um you know
working with incarcerated writers you're
not going to set that
in a juvenile detention center
maybe no you want it to be in you know
in
a very specific sort of like type of
prison to inform that world right
um so i think that you should pay
attention to the where um if we're
talking about
the the the process of actually
conveying that on the page
um i think that you know the trick of
screenwriting
right is to be as concise as possible
but as evocative as possible as possible
in those few words so
um so that's the trick of conveying it
on the page is
um being deliberate about your choice
and then conveying it as specifically
as possible so that you can get as much
out of your choice
as you can does that make sense it does
so
fade in if we're talking about let's say
this library this hypothetically fade in
that's where i'm having
how much detail am i using um yeah well
so early
in your screenplay you probably um
because you're just introducing us
to the world of your story you'll
probably take a little bit more time
to convey where we are the the feel and
the tone of where we are
and maybe the important characteristics
of that setting
right um and then as your script
progresses you'll probably need to
describe
less both because we've probably already
seen a lot of these locations
and then also because you want that you
want your story to move fast right so
as as you go further along
in the screenplay you'll probably spend
less time establishing locations
uh than you did at the very beginning
when you were trying to establish the
world and create that world in our minds
so that we could
live in it for the duration of your
story now that said i
i think that there's um there's also
value though in knowing which
moments in your screenplay should
breathe
and when you have a moment that you that
you need to sort of give space to
that might be when you bring us into the
world
for a little bit you know longer of a
moment with some extra detail or telling
us what's going on in that scene or
something like that
does that make sense it does yeah um is
that the same for when we're doing a
character description in the beginning
like if we use this hypothetical
librarian
she's 35 straight blonde hair
um maybe a little bit uh
dark under the eyes from staying up all
night reading but yeah i don't know yeah
yeah well so a lot of there's a lot of
emphasis put on those um character
introductions right
i think um i have two minds about this i
think that
people get caught up in writing like the
perfect character introduction i think
that they are important because the
first time we meet your character you
want to give us a sense of
who they are sort of concisely and um
evocatively right um but
you know i've seen some character
introductions that
that are that are a little too long that
maybe like
stop the story in order to give us a lot
of information about the character
the moment we meet them um which can be
you know if you're reading a script it
can
it can really pull you out if you if you
are forced to
stop the scene and meet this person
that feels like it interrupts the flow
of the story right
so i think the the trick of writing
character introductions
again is the same with with all
screenwriting which is
be as concise as you can but as
evocative as you can
um and what you're trying to convey when
you introduce the character
is give us that sort of like defining
quality about them that essence of the
character that's going to be important
to the story
so physical descriptions might not be as
useful to us
right because we might i mean the blonde
hair might never come into play
in the story right but it might be
useful to know that she's
overworked or that she's burning the
midnight oil or you know that might be
important to the story in the situation
that she finds herself in so
stuff like that could be useful and you
just have to sort of determine like
what's the most
um sort of defining quality about this
character that i need
my reader to understand right now as i
introduce them
do you think the first scene or sort of
sentence
in a screenplay is as important the way
maybe the first sentence in a novel
that's a good question i haven't thought
about it but um i would say no
um only because i think in a novel well
i don't know when you're reading a novel
you're going to give it more than one
sentence
right i mean if you've picked up a novel
to read
you're you're probably pretty interested
in it already
um in a screenplay i have
heard so it depends on the situation uh
if i am reading this entire script and i
already know i'm reading it front to
back
then that first sentence if it's clunky
i'm i'm going to give it
a little bit of leeway i'm going to give
it another chance right so i'm going to
keep reading regardless
um i have heard some people say
that they can tell if they're going to
keep reading a script
from the first sentence if they read the
first sentence and they're not hooked or
it feels like the person doesn't really
know what they're doing
then they're going to put it down i
would say that's an extreme that's an
extreme opinion
um but you know you also have to
understand that if we're talking about a
situation
where you are submitting your script to
be read by somebody in the industry
you're asking for their time right um
how much time they're willing to give
you is up to them so
the best thing you can do is make sure
that every sentence of your screenplay
is worth reading and makes them want to
read the next one right that's
you have to set yourself up for success
um because there's no guarantee
that they're going to read your whole
script that's fair
right and then this is by the way you
said you're you're hearing this from
producers or agents or whatever you've
heard this is not necessarily your
opinion
right but it's just yes i mean i very
rarely
pick up a script just to read one
sentence and see if i like it or not
um but you know it depends on the
situation so if
if someone is a if someone's reading a
lot of scripts if they're
vetting scripts for a producer say and
they're just looking for something
really
great they might they might only give it
a page or two pages they might
you know um back in the day when i was
reading a lot of scripts for a producer
and so it wasn't
i wasn't reading the scripts to try to
give notes and help make them better i
wasn't working on a project
it was just vetting projects to see if
there was anything interesting or worth
reading the whole script
um you know it wasn't uncommon to read
the first act or even read to where the
inciting incident should be and see if
anything's happening see if there's
anything to like sort of catch my
interest and make me want to keep
reading this script so
um i think if you're submitting your
scripts to producer
or a manager an agent you should assume
that you need to hook their attention
you know
at least in the first few pages if not
on the first
page itself and this goes back to the
the story that you said about
being from oregon and you know hey how's
it going when you're working at a
production company
really and then and and when you called
the los angeles area
it was more protocol for them to just
kind of be like yeah what do you need
yeah well-intentioned i'm sure they are
but but
that's the tempo of of the industry and
it wasn't to
find out you know how your day was going
yes exactly the the pace in la that's
what surprised me
when you know comparing oregon to
california
uh from portland to la the pace is
definitely a lot faster and that took
some getting used to
but yes i think that speaks to that's
exactly right like people
working in the industry are short on
time and there's a lot of material to
get through
and so you have to make your material
grab them and and make them want to keep
reading and that's
that's a challenge you know
what are springboards and sequences so i
did not invent springboards and
sequences and
unfortunately i can't remember where i
picked this up but i think it's a really
useful thing
when you're trying to figure out kind of
that
um well it's really useful when you're
trying to figure out act two right
because it allows you to break your
story down into smaller chunks
so sequences a lot of people have heard
of um
you can think of your movie as sort of
eight sequences um
two sequences in act one four sequences
in act two
two sequences in act three right so
that's sort of the division of sequences
across your three-act structure
um it's it's pretty common to look at
movies in sort of that sequence
structure
uh the springboards i think are the real
bonus of of this
uh exercise that i sort of help writers
with which is coming up with that
um that event or turning point or plot
point
that ends one sequence and launches the
next one and that
it's just a way for you to sort of start
planning out your story so that there's
a real sense of cause and effect
and it breaks it down into manageable
chunks when you are plotting or even
when you're writing
um i do this and i i teach this method
which is uh
to outline in sequences so you only have
to focus on one sequence at a time
which makes it less daunting to approach
your your entire story
if we were to look at crash and i know
you said that that was one of the most
difficult
of the 50 or you know yeah great awesome
film but yeah in terms of the structure
what would be some of those springboards
that's a good question i haven't
actually seen crash
in so long that it would be tough
but um but i will say if you're if
you're looking at sort of
um the way springboards and sequences
overlay
onto onto the three-act structure right
and it does it they
they line right up and it's um i'm
certainly not saying that every movie
has to have eight equal sequences across
the movie but this is just a method to
help you to help you plot
your story and you may deviate from this
as you find your story right so every
story is unique and you have to serve
that story the story that you're telling
but it gives you a starting point so if
i if i am coming out of story and i just
really don't know anything yet i start
thinking in the springboards and
sequences because that gives me
sort of containers to think about what
needs to happen in each section of the
script
um and then as i find what needs to
happen in each section i might go oh
i only need one sequence here i only
need you know maybe i need three short
sequences here or whatever
but it just gives you a starting point
to sort of break your story
um and then if you're uh we were talking
about
what it you know what is a springboard
and sort of where do they fall um
your kind of big turning points
naturally are springboards so your
inciting incident
is your first springboard right so you
have a sequence of your story that's
going to be all set up really
introducing your protagonist
establishing the world all that stuff
what's their life like right now
and then that sequence will end in the
inciting incident which is a springboard
that launches the next sequence so
because of that inciting incident
your protagonist now has some sort of
problem or opportunity that they're
going to have to deal with right
and that is what sequence 2 is about so
it's like what are they going to do with
this how are they going to contend with
it
what happens if they don't deal with it
what's at stake you know all that stuff
closing all those like sort of immediate
doors to convince us that they're going
to take that act two journey so
you work through that sequence and then
that ends in
the next springboard which is your break
into two right so then you have a big
sort of plot turn at that moment which
is
usually your protagonist deciding yes
i'm gonna go do this thing
here's my plan for solving this big
problem in my life that's your
springboard that launches you into
sequence three
so so the the sort of um springboard and
sequences
that we use as like a framework to sort
of to start figuring out your story
really just lays on top of 3x structure
and a lot of your major turning points
that you have
probably already thought of those are
going to be springboards anyway
so if i was going to take let's say
going back to this librarian with
the with the bad boy boyfriend i like
this story
too if she let's suppose she's called
into
the administrator's office for this
central library and they say
i need to have a seat uh listen we do
not
advocate dating people that are within
our programs here
and is that a springboard or her
springboard would then be to make a
decision
let's suppose she's still allowed to
keep her job but she's been given
like a reprimand and it's going in her
file
what part would actually be a
springboard well so um i actually think
it's both of those things so it's the
event
that turns the story in a new direction
or launches the next sort of sequence of
events
but that is going to be led off by your
character's reaction to that event so
it might be um you know she she's sat
down by her
superior they say you have a choice you
can either
keep your job or keep the guy and then
her reaction to that is
is really what we're watching over the
next sequence so that sequence is going
to start with her
probably making some sort of decision
right
um it'll probably probably be in the
next scene
or it might not um but
long story short the springboard would
would be the event and then her reaction
to it would be what
what would be tracking over the next
sequence probably
right okay because let's say then she
goes like on the subway and maybe she
sees couples together
and she's kind of like sizing up like
hmm
is this where i fit in to couple them
with like you know you know i've
chosen someone that's maybe outside my
circle of friends yeah
well so that's actually a good example
because i think that it um
the the options that you brought up it
could work both ways so the springboard
could be
she sat down and told you have to make
this choice and then the next sequence
might be about us
watching her make that choice right
or that the next sequence might be after
she
she walks out of that office knowing
she's gonna ditch the job and and go
with the guy
then the next sequence might be her
trying to convince him
that they're in it together and there's
no one else and whatever you know what i
mean so it just kind of depends on your
story
um that's why i said it's just a it's
just a framework to sort of help us
you know start breaking your story and
think about like what needs to happen in
each
in each um section of your story great
yeah thank you
okay great yeah this script is coming
together and i'm not even gonna write it
how do we know if the plot progression
in a screenplay makes sense
well i mean i think that there's it's
just common sense you're gonna you're
gonna sort of like
follow the logic of your story um is
that
is that what you mean yeah i mean do we
do how do we maybe i guess the better
question is
what if the plot progression is taking
too long uh
maybe that's a better question that's a
good question my question's taking that
sorry no no no that's a good question um
so
so i think that that is subjective right
and it depends on what you're going for
it depends on the story you're telling
the pace that you sort of expect from a
story in that genre
and that style um so there's there's no
you know black and white answer but um
i do think that when you're reading a
script right one of the one of the big
red flags
is boredom so this might be something
that
you can only figure out once you have
sort of figured out your your entire
plot and you get fresh eyes on it you
might think
you know that it moves like a runaway
train and then you might have somebody
else look at it and they say
oh gosh when is it when's it going to
get going when's it going to start right
so um i mean i think that the
sort of natural approach is to get your
start
get your story moving as quickly as
possible and make sure that you are
escalating the conflict and escalating
the stakes
consistently throughout your story and
um
and building on that throughout all of
act two but if you've done that and
you've broken the story you've plotted
the whole thing out you think it's great
i would still say get a fresh set of
eyes on it so you can see
if everyone else agrees with you and
they think that you're
the pace is okay of your story as well
right because there's there's pacing
that's too fast
yeah and that's what we were talking
about with letting moments breathe
too right um because we want to
sort of see the emotional reactions of
stories too we don't
i mean sometimes we do want just an
action movie that just moves from action
to action right
but more often i think we're interested
in
what is the effect of this plot on this
character that's what we actually care
about
when we're watching a movie or reading a
script right
we want to know like what is the
experience like for this person
going through this what are they feeling
what are they thinking how is this
causing them to change or re-prioritize
what what's in their life
um so i think it yes pace
in a script can be too fast at times um
if it doesn't give us those
those moments of reaction and sort of
you know processing
emotions so that we understand what's
the emotional journey
of this story as well not just the plot
great yeah and going back to like
biopics i think sometimes
what they fall short in is the pacing's
too fast because they're trying to cram
too much
yeah but and i know we were just talking
about seaburg off camera i i thought the
pacing was great
so but well you have to see it but yeah
biopics are tough because
um i think a lot of times people try to
make
a story of someone's entire life you
know or that maybe that's the instinct
of like this was such an iconic person i
want to tell the whole story of their
entire life
and very few people's lives are actually
one story you know like most of our
lives are episodic
right so you have to pick what is the
episode
from your life that's a transformative
defining experience and then tell that
story don't
don't tell me the whole thing just give
me the that transformative experience
great point yeah and i think that's what
it did for the most part yeah
it didn't it didn't totally follow her
whole her whole journey
do screenwriters need to know about
timelines yeah i mean i think that
there's definitely
um it's worth paying attention to the
timeline of your story because there's a
certain
flow that when you're reading a script
if
that if the if the sort of flow of logic
or
our sense of how much time is passing in
the story if that is off
or you know unclear that can be
disorienting and can make
reading it confusing so definitely worth
paying attention to
um it's it's not a problem i see that
often
but occasionally it does come up where i
can't figure out
so if this event happened then how much
time has passed
you know so um i think that goes to
clarity which is
one thing that you're always striving
for in your script is conveying as
clearly as possible
exactly what you know exactly what the
story is what's happening
so that we can understand kind of the
you know the journey that you're taking
us on yeah i think it's hard too when
there's like they're jumping
back and forth in someone's memory or
they're they're showing different
people's realities and so that timeline
becomes blurred but
yeah i'm not sure the best way to convey
that um
are you are you working different
timelines into your librarian story
we could we could try that yeah okay so
if we were going to use that i know
people were going to be like okay move
on with the librarian but
if we let's suppose we wanted the
librarian to think
back to growing up and maybe
the perfect boy that her parents wanted
her to marry
and she just didn't want that she wanted
somebody that had more
edges around them so she kind of maybe
he was like the local
business owner son he was like the
perfect guy on paper
but there was nothing there for her yeah
and then she remembers like the bad kid
and having a crush on this guy and so
that takes her back now
to being 35 and working in this
you know city library and she's
regarded amongst her peers but she still
has something for this
sort of rough around the edges writer
who's a little bitter and arms cross and
challenges her
but she likes that yeah well i have a
couple of thoughts about this story
so um no so i think it's great so um so
i would say
you're um you are sort of talking about
flashbacks right which is a which is a
topic worth talking about um
i think that flashbacks you can use i
know a lot of people say don't use
flashbacks that are
you know outlawed or whatever you can
totally use flashbacks if we need that
information to understand the story that
we're watching in the present
time you know what i mean um if it gives
me context
that i need in order to appreciate
understand feel whatever the story is
that you're telling me right now then i
think it's valid um i would say in that
case
i don't necessarily need to know that
she had a crush on a bad boy
in her childhood in order to understand
the attraction to the bad boy today
right because i think that's a pretty
common thing
pretty common trope for romances right
that women like bad boys so
i would say because everyone already
gets that you don't have to explain it
to us by saying she had this past
that where she had a crush on a bad boy
also
just in general i would say with romance
stories um
try to keep just one love interest
unless you have
unless they're directly competing right
and so you have like a sort of a love
triangle or something like that
um which is very common as well but if
if we're introduced to someone else that
she was in love with and then now we're
supposed to invest in her being in love
with this person
that can get a little bit muddy and sort
of divide our
our loyalties like who do we want her to
be with right
which is exactly the the effect that you
want with a love triangle but in this
instance like you're not you're not
talking about a love triangle you're
talking about
a backstory that is informing her
um romantic ideal today right right yeah
yeah i was just thinking so that
wouldn't really be a competing timeline
that's more just
just a memory like a flashback sequence
right i mean i think that um there
there definitely are stories that maybe
could be told in parallel timelines
right
and if we're going to take the librarian
example one step further so maybe there
is a
um maybe there is a timeline of when she
was 10 years old and
i i don't know actually i don't think
there is but okay i was gonna say
in some stories there are parallel
timelines or you know
two different sort of stories that are
happening in different timelines
um trying to think like the hours i
think was one okay
right do you remember that movie yeah um
it was like three different timelines
in one story and so they chose to do
that i guess
the point that i'm making is they chose
um
to tell the story across different
timelines for a deliberate effect
so that really is the goal before you
make any
um sort of style or structural choices
is understanding what is the effect that
you're trying to have on the audience
um and so then how do i achieve that
effect right so
if i'm trying to um draw out some
mystery
about why she's in love with this guy
then maybe
i want another you know a series of
flashbacks
alluding to some you know romance that
she had years and years ago or something
like that maybe that could be effective
but
but the point being that um i would i
would only make
that choice knowing that i want to have
this effect on the audience i want them
to be curious about how did this woman
get to be this way
and so then that's the effect that i
would be trying to achieve with those
flashbacks does that make sense
it does yeah so maybe she remembers
going to the dance with the good guy and
then she saw the bad boy smoking outside
and he amazed like he makes like a snide
comment to her but there's part of like
this
he's also like fishing at the same time
and so she kind of remembers
tommy and his tux or whatever you know i
will say the danger of that and this is
this again goes back to clarity
which is um you have to understand what
your audience is going to see when they
see that flashback
are they going to know that that's a
different bad boy than the one you're
presenting us with
today right so we might be watching it
and going like oh they've met before she
she actually had a crush on him when she
was a teenager right and that could
change how we understand your story um
it could also just confuse us and
make us wonder like what what is it with
this woman and
this guy i don't know what's happening
with them so that's a good point so
maybe that's too much
backstory could be yeah it could be also
also i will say if you if you are
writing that story and you want to put
that backstory in
it could be something that you don't
need a flashback for and you can just
get in through you know conversation or
something like that
ah okay maybe like um having drinks with
an old college friend or something
something said right because it feels
like that piece of information is
fairly small so is it worth stopping the
story flashing back to a completely
different time a completely different
cast of characters except your
protagonist
just to let us know that she sort of
always had a thing for bad boys you know
that's something that you can probably
get out in you know a line of dialogue
sure sure like a bartender walks by and
she's just like
you know i'll take a martini from him i
don't know that's way too cliche sorry
okay
what do writers get wrong about writing
supporting characters
oh um well i don't know that they
necessarily get it wrong but i think one
thing that could make
some supporting characters stronger and
screenplays in general stronger is
connecting the supporting characters to
the theme a little bit more
um i think sometimes writers throw in
you know the wacky sidekick
or you know a supporting character who's
just really colorful and their first
comedic effect or
you know a sort of a distraction from
the a story
but really you want your screenplay
to be a collection of things that are
all having the same conversation right
so you want your screenplay to be having
one conversation all the way through
and all of those pieces should connect
to that conversation they should all
fall under that umbrella we're just
going to mix
mixed metaphors so um but uh
yeah so when you're when you're
inventing your supporting characters if
you can think about their
relationship with the theme that's a
useful
um a useful way to invent a supporting
character that feels integrated into the
fabric of the story and has
a function in your story as well because
your supporting characters should be
pushing your character
either toward or away from the lesson
that they're trying to learn from this
series of events right that is the
lesson of the theme
and so if your supporting character has
a function
that relates to that theme so either
they set a good example
that leads your character toward this
you know revelation that they're going
to have eventually
or if they are a cautionary tale if you
don't learn the lesson of the theme this
is what you'll turn
into those are just two examples but you
can connect your supporting characters
to the theme
in ways like that and then that will
both um
make them feel integrated into the that
one conversation that your story is
having and then also
contribute to the growth of your
character either by pushing them
toward the lesson that they need or
providing more conflict
and causing them to to struggle toward
that lesson as well
well maybe we could move on to another
film and not my idea which is maybe
bridesmaids oh sure
so if we look at the supporting
characters in that
yeah how did that move the main
character more toward her goal
well so interestingly um those brides
the collection of bridesmaids in
bridesmaids has sort of like
two aspects to them that i think is
really interesting
on the one hand they each um
provide a different outlook on marriage
or a different sort of like
phase of marriage relationships right so
you have kind of the
the newly married um doe-eyed you know
idealist
you have the uh the like resolutely
single
playing the field melissa mccarthy right
you have the woman who's been married so
long she has like
three sons and she she is tired of her
husband
right um you have helen who's kind of
the board trophy wife
um and i think that's it right it's
those four and then kristen wiig
and so they each represent kind of a
different version
of marriage um and you know the whole
we're we're setting this story in the
world of weddings and marriage and
getting married and all that stuff so
that's very fitting
um but if you look at it as well they
each
provide a different sort of attitude
about um growth and change right
so and that's really the journey that
kristen wiig is on in this
in this movie she's trying to get
unstuck from her life
um each of those characters have
if you could look at it that they each
have sort of a different perspective or
uh relationship to just being stuck or
being
you know making progress in your life so
the newly married one
she's excited for everything that's to
come like all she has is sort of like
rainbows and roses in her future and she
can't wait to be married forever
i think she says that at one point in
the in the movie um
the woman who's been married too long
she has she feels stuck
and um in a rut in her in her marriage
like this is how things are
this is how they will always be it's
awful she needs to escape to vegas right
um the the woman helen
who uh is kind of the trophy wife and
the big antagonist
she um she is not happy with the way
things are
in her life but she is going about
changing them in
uh you know in maybe an unhealthy way we
could look at it right so she
and kristen wiig are sort of both
equally as stuck in their lives but
they're stuck in very different lives um
and who am i missing oh melissa mccarthy
she is she welcomes all change she says
yes to everything
you know so they all have a relationship
to sort of
change and being stuck or making
progress or you know that
that kind of like realm which is really
what the thematic stuff of that movie is
excellent i love it yeah i want to go
watch it oh good
i'm hoping we can talk about a character
with a goal and a character with no goal
and how would i be able to see that my
screenplay
has like a character with a weak goal oh
interesting well
so um i think most movies that you watch
most mainstream movies that you watch
are really built around a character
pursuing something right
so i would say they all they all have
pretty definable goals um
any movie that you'll see that's like in
the theater
i take that back not any movie that
you'll see most movies that you'll see
they're designed around somebody who
wants something very badly
and goes after it right um so
uh i would say if you're trying to
figure out
whether your character has a weak goal
um probably the places that i would
start would be at your break into two
this is assuming you've already written
the script right
at your break into two do we know what
your character is going to be pursuing
over the rest of the movie that is
that's their goal
that's you might not always think of it
as a goal it might be
you might think of it as just a conflict
like this character and this character
are competing for the same prize or
something like that
you could look at it that way but we
know what we're tracking over that
entire movie right
um so i would say establishing that goal
is one part of the
question that you're asking and then the
other ques the other part is
whether they're pursuing that goal right
and we want them to be pursuing it
consistently
and um against great odds and opposition
right throughout the entire movie and so
that is uh something that you'd have to
evaluate is my character
in virtually every scene are they
pursuing that goal that big picture
thing that they're trying to accomplish
and if they are are they also running
into
um you know some form of antagonism
that's keeping them
from making progress too quickly or
achieving that goal right away without
anything standing in their way because
we want both of those things we want a
strong goal
but we also want your character to
pursue it actively
and have to really try to get it right
so with with bridesmaids if we go back
to that movie as an example
if we look at her her goals
is the goal to win the friendship of the
one friend or to
show up the other woman well so
i would say i would say that the um the
goal in that movie
is for her to be her best friend's maid
of honor right
and um the method remember we talked
about the method
that she's going to use is by competing
with
helen right so um so she won't always
have to compete with helen
in order to achieve that goal but that's
that's her main force of antagonism so
she really is gonna have to
compete with helen most of the time um
and then i would say what's at stake in
that movie
is her friendship among other things but
if we're
you know we're just sort of laying out
the the the sort of
building blocks of the setup that's um
how i would kind of delineate them
does that make sense it does and so if
i'm writing a script and
someone's not clear on like why my
character is doing certain things does
that
maybe indicate that the goal the hero's
goal is not very
clear well if we know what they're
trying to do then i would say the goal
is clear but if we're not sure
why they're doing something i would say
either
there's just a sort of a you know a plot
logic problem like we don't understand
why they think this thing is what they
need to do
or it could also be a stakes problem so
we don't understand
why we don't understand why they're
taking on this goal in the first place
because we don't understand
what it means to them or what will
happen if they don't take it on
or what happens if they fail you know
all of those things we need to really
understand
sort of the motivation behind your
character's actions and
a lot of times that has to do with
stakes
how does a writer effectively write
overlapping dialogue between
characters there's a function in final
draft that you just
okay well actually there are
there are a couple of different i mean
really it all goes back to clarity so
you're just trying to convey right what
we're going to be seeing and hearing on
screen
as clearly as you can on the page and so
there's a couple different things you
can do there really is the dual dialog
function right where you can have two
characters speaking at the same time
they each have individual lines and
they're just set side by side
or if you want a little bit like sort of
of a messier ongoing conversation
i would say you'd probably just you know
um
sort of structure your dialogue so that
you don't have complete sentences you
have
sentences that are ending in a dash so
that we know that one character is
cutting off the other character make
sure they're using
like pretty short um sides of dialogue
so that it
it reads with that rhythm where it feels
like you know one person's overlapping
over another one if that's the effect
that you're going for right like i'm
thinking of uncut gems
oh you haven't okay um how about
moonstruck sure
yeah there was a lot of yelling and you
know and getting mad or even
my big fat greek wedding same type of
thing you know a lot of
but that's like that's just how
everybody was in that setting
interacting yeah i mean i think the the
goal of the screenwriter is probably
always to
convey as much of the feel of that on
the page as you can
and then of course you know when when
it's um
in production you'll you'll have some
direction to help you out too
right right and it was all in a loving
way yeah it just that's how they
communicate
right right
what is subplot um what is
subplot um i would say
i would say a true subplot is any um
is any plot separate from or plot lines
separate from the a story that has its
own
sort of goal and uh through line right
so a through line is going to be created
by the pursuit of a goal
so it could be your protagonist with
another goal that they're trying to
pursue
i guess maybe the most common example
that we could pull up would be
you know your character is trying to rob
a series of banks
and then there's a romantic subplot so
he's also
trying to have a romantic relationship
with someone
that has nothing to do with the banks
right it's its own goal that has its own
arc through the movie
um so i would call that a true subplot
you could also have a
subplot that's driven by another
character so your protagonist is robbing
a
series of banks unbeknownst to him or or
known to him
uh his brother is trying to win custody
of his child right so
separate goal separate it's going to
have its own arc in the story
probably won't have equal weight that's
why we call it a subplot right because
you want your focus to be on the a story
but it'll have its own there's a
separate
goal that's being pursued that has its
own through line why do we need
subplot um i think you could argue that
not all stories not all movies need
subplots right like sometimes we watch
movies and it
sort of feels like everything is just
connected to that a story and we don't
really have
separate true subplots um
but i think depending on the effect that
you're trying to achieve
and the sort of takeaway message that
you're trying to give with your story
sometimes a subplot can complement that
so
trying to think of a good example i feel
like um
in jerry maguire yeah right like the rod
tidwell
getting his getting his new offer from
the team or whatever
it's been a while since i've seen the
movie but i feel like that was a true
subplot because it was um
if i remember right it was jerry trying
to get an offer for his
for his client right so it would have
been jerry jerry's
sort of separate goal is that right
gosh now i don't remember and i think he
really needed rod didn't he because he
was like his biggest client
yeah just kind of a stakes thing yeah
now i'm getting now i'm confusing myself
i'm not sure if that's right but i think
that's true so i think the subplot was
he's trying to get a deal or an offer
for rod tidwell from
um from arizona right his current uh his
current team
that subplot was necessary
to jerry maguire's story because it um
it complemented his learning that lesson
of the theme which is
that you have to play with with heart
right you have to like
um stop being calculated and strategic
sometimes and just
put your whole heart into it right um so
i think that you can look at subplots as
helping to
again teach your protagonist the lesson
that they need to learn from this series
of events
so jerry gets fired and he um he starts
his own company
and um his romance with dorothy i think
is a subplot right because that's a
separate goal he's having a
there they they very much overlap and a
lot of times they happen in the same
scenes right where there are these two
plot lines being pushed forward at the
same time um
but starting his business and and making
it a success
gosh now that i'm thinking about it the
red tid will thing might be part of that
and then the subplot of the romance
would be would be a separate um
storyline that would be the romantic
subplot that he's pursuing
sure yeah i guess so i mean can so can a
film have many subplots or do they oh
they can't okay
yeah yeah oh i definitely think so um
and i think that
um how much weight a subplot has
can vary greatly like you can have you
know
a romance subplot that actually is
nearly equal with the a story
um or you can have something that ends
up looking like sort of a runner through
your script where it's like
maybe it is a minor goal that the
character is pursuing but we only need
to see
three or four scenes where it's like
introduced pursued and then accomplished
or whatever so
um i think you can have lots of subplots
um
my caution about having subplots would
be
just be careful that our focus stays on
the a story
because if you have too many subplots it
can
if you have too many subplots and you're
not um keeping our focus on that
main storyline like that main conflict
that we're watching right
um it can end up feeling like we don't
know which story we're supposed to be
paying attention to
uh it can feel sort of scattered so
that's the only thing i would say
be careful of but most people are when
they come at writing a screenplay they
have a pretty good sense of like what's
that main story that they're trying to
tell
well because is is it dorothy is the is
the renee
yeah okay because she has her own
subplot in that
and i don't even know if you'd call it
that but that she's living with her
sister
and her sister i guess it's like a
divorcee and older and maybe a little
more bitter
and the great scene of like renee
and tom coming into the women's group
and kind of like
they all just shoot these daggers at
time you know and he's trying to prove
that he's a good guy
yeah and and and and against all odds
like he is a good guy and that
she has this sister character who's real
doubtful and
just trying to fight against that so you
see renee and her situation
and i don't know if that's also a
subplot well so i would i would say that
you could look at the subplot
so renee zellweger i think dorothy has
her has
um the romance subplot we look at it
from her point of view as well right so
we actually
see that relationship from both points
of view i would say that
her relationship with her sister is just
a relationship and it's not
its own subplot because they're not
renee isn't necessarily pursuing
anything
i don't think her sister is either there
there isn't really a goal that that
we're sort of
seeing the goal established and then
seeing them pursue it and conflict and
then
resolution right so i would say it's
just a
i would call that a relationship with a
supporting character
um and i would say that that supporting
character
uh is is one of the benefits of the
sister is that she
helps she helps dorothy reflect on like
what she really wants in life
the you know the um the sort of role of
love
in her life and how much she needs how
much she's willing to settle for right
which is
kind of in that same thematic umbrella
when you're reading screenplays from
unknown writers how far into the
screenplay do you know
whether it's good or bad yeah well i
think problems can show up
very early in a script right um but they
don't always
so so some scripts have a great setup
they have a great first act and they
you know sort of have the right pace
right away they get the story rolling
and we feel like things are happening
we're invested
and then in act two things
fall apart basically like if their
protagonist stops pursuing the goal we
don't really know what's going on
so um i mean i guess the answer is
if if a script has global problems that
sort of cover the entire script then
you'll
probably know within the first five
pages or so
um definitely i think if it has
if it has like major structural problems
with
all the structure overall structure as a
whole i would say
by by you know page 15 or so you know
that there's a problem because you're
waiting for something to happen
and one of the most common problems is
that nothing's happening
right like it's just not getting going
so um so i would say that you can know
right away you can know pretty quickly
that a script has some issues or needs
some work
um but i would also say you can't always
tell what a script or
often you can't tell what a script's
issues are until later until you've seen
sort of what they're trying to
accomplish or gotten a true sense of
like
what the story really is or what they're
going for and a lot of times you don't
have that
sense of what they're going for until
later in the script until
towards the end of act 2 at least you
know so that
that probably sheds light on the need
for
really having your script in good shape
before you submit it and it's not
it's not your personal thing it's more
of an industry standard that
if something within the first few pages
isn't good it's just going to be
rejected for time's sake
yeah i will say so usually when i'm
reading a script i'm reading it to help
right i'm reading it to try to figure
out what isn't working and see where i
can
provide that insight to the writer so
that they can make it better
a lot of people in the industry as you
know are not reading for that purpose
they're
they're looking for projects that they
want to get involved in and so
since you are submitting your script
sort of asking someone to get involved
in your project
um hopefully what you've submitted will
get them excited and interested right
away so you
want to be able to get them interested
on page one
get them sort of hooked in the story by
that inciting incident
um you know build and escalate your
story
uh sort of throughout the rest as their
as the characters pursuing that goal so
that their
your reader is invested and emotionally
engaged and all that stuff through the
whole thing and then you want to deliver
like some emotionally satisfying
resolution and hopefully some genuine
emotion by the end of the story as well
so that they come the reader comes away
from your script
moved and or entertained in some way you
know so that they want to
get involved and help you make it if we
look back at let's say the recording
industry they would say well
put the best three songs up front first
because some a r person or what i don't
know i
don't really know too much about the
music industry but i just remember
hearing that that
they're going to be listening to those
three and if by maybe one or two in it's
not good
it goes it goes in in a bad pile so yeah
although i
you know i mean the other the sort of
flip side of
doing that i guess there's a lot of
emphasis placed
on making sure that your first 10 pages
is so good and really hooky
and grabs your reader which is great of
course you want it to do that
but i have read scripts where it was
very clear that the first 10 pages were
were really worked on and then after
that there there were clear
issues that still hadn't been addressed
and you know so you don't want that
either you want
you want a great strong start that hooks
your reader but then you want to
deliver on what you've promised them you
want them to
become emotionally invested and to stay
engaged all the way through and to
really care about the outcome and
and to feel something at the end you
know interesting okay so so then
you can't really cheat it where you're
like i'm gonna make these 10 pages the
top three songs of the album
and then it turns out that the rest of
it is just all b-side stuff that no one
wants to listen to yeah
and and that's gonna that's gonna bite
you in the end yeah i don't think you
can do that because the purpose of
making your first 10 pages really really
strong
is to get someone to read the rest of it
right so
the rest of it has to be worth reading
too
is editing rewriting is editing
rewriting well i guess it depends on
what you mean by editing um i would
think of editing as just sort of like
making little tweaks and and sort of
language polishes or like you know
shining up the words on the page right
um i wouldn't
i wouldn't really consider that true
rewriting
i think that is actually something that
people do as they say they're rewriting
their script but really they're just
like
moving words around and making it sound
better which is which is a valid path
that you want to take on your script
that that sort of polish where you're
making sure that it reads
really well all the way through but
rewriting is a skill that
really separates sort of newer writers
from
professionals or more experienced
writers because
being able to sort of understand what's
not working
about your script and then figuring out
how to rewrite how to how to adjust
in order to address that issue is that
is a it's a
it's a skill that takes people i think a
long time to sort of really figure out a
lot of times
people want to rewrite by by making like
surgical changes going in and changing
one line of dialogue or
you know um oh that logic wasn't clear
okay i'll just add this line of dialogue
here and that'll address it and
sometimes that works but not always and
so if you have
a sort of a more global problem or
something that can't be fixed in a line
of dialogue
knowing how to kind of like pull the
engine apart
fix the pieces or change out the pieces
and then put it back together again
that's a whole
other skill set that's very important to
know
so so there's there's polishing which
might be
adding more finesse to a word or just
just do something more descriptive
but then rewriting is really if you're
changing something in act one it's
probably gonna have to go in
and be tweaked it toward the end yeah as
well okay yeah and i think that's the
part that
people don't like to hear is you know um
a lot of times the notes that you'll get
from you know whoever's reading your
script uh
they'll you know they'll be things that
can't be changed in a line of dialogue
they might
they might mostly be addressed in the
setup or in act one
but then they'll have a domino effect
where okay well now that that's working
or that that feels right or is solid
then you have to think about like where
where does this domino
effect go in the rest of your script
right like where else
does where else needs you know needs to
be tightened up or
or fixed addressed whatever in order to
kind of like carry that all the way
through carry the effect all the way
through so that that
note is fully addressed and not just
kind of like band-aid you know
is there screenwriting software that
lets you know
like you know danger danger you've
changed this this is a major like
structured
i don't think there is but also it's
because i don't i don't think that
um i i i mean that would be amazing if
there was
software that could do that but i don't
think there is because i think
it's uh it's not something that
is necessarily that
that black and white in terms of like
the effect that it's going to have if i
change it in this scene then i
you know if i change it in scene 3 then
i have to go to scene 30 and change that
i don't think that
those relationships are always um going
to be true because
like we talked about every story is
different and every screenplay is
different right
so i think the skill the reason that
rewriting is so hard is because the
skill it requires is being able to
understand
being able to understand how your story
works and
how each of the pieces is
working together and having an effect on
the story so that when you change
one you understand okay now that i have
changed this piece and it's having this
effect that means that the engine is
going to be lopsided over here or
whatever and i need to
adjust these other things i feel like
that's not a very clear example
so basically it's a human skill it can't
be at this point can't be
done via ai or some other scraping tool
that's going to know
yes i mean i like i said i think that
would be great if if there was something
like that
maybe there could be something that that
um
uh sort of flagged scenes that you might
want to look at right
but i do think it's a more it's it's
really um
it's really like seeing in story right
like being able to look at the
screenplay and understanding
the story as an engine that
all the pieces work together and so if
you change one
which other pieces need to be adjusted
you know
what are stakes and sacrifice and how do
they work together
oh that's a good question um so so
commonly we think about stakes in your
story as the
consequence or the thing that will
happen if your character fails to
achieve their goal
right so um like we were talking about
in bridesmaids
if uh kristen wiig fails at
being her best friend's maid of honor
then her friendship is
her friendship will probably fail or you
know
her friendship's at stake so their her
friendship will take a hit right
um she may lose her best friend so
that's what's at stake is her friendship
with
uh lillian um sacrifice
is it's this is you know this is sort of
a story nerd distinction
to look at because you can kind of lump
all of these things together
but sacrifice is what your character
is sort of the cost of participation of
your character
taking on this goal or this task that
they're trying to do right
so the the cost of participation
tells us um how important a goal
is to someone if they're really willing
to
sacrifice a lot in order to pursue this
thing right so
bridesmaids isn't a great example but
just say that in order to
go for the olympic gold i have to give
up my family
my girlfriend my job all this stuff
those are all
cost of participation things those are
all sacrifices that i'm making
in order to pursue this goal what's at
stake if i
don't win the gold is perhaps my olympic
gymnastics career right so those are two
different things so my career is at
stake
that is hanging in the balance but the
sacrifices that i'm making
are separate from that however the
sacrifices can help me see how important
this goal is to this character because
i'm willing to sacrifice all that stuff
in pursuit of it
the challenge with sacrifice is making
sure that the sacrifice isn't so
big and unwarranted that the audience
then thinks your character's stupid
right because if they're giving up all
this stuff and it feels like
but they're giving up all the stuff for
what for this goal that you know to
to enter the the town race to win a a
new griddle or something like that
doesn't seem like it's worth giving up
all this stuff so your audience won't
get on board with your character
pursuing a goal that doesn't seem
to warrant all the sacrifice that
they're making an example that i always
use is the ring so the ring is about a
woman who
um who watches a cursed videotape and
then she has seven days
to solve the mystery of this curse in
order to stop it
and save her life right so what's at
stake
in that pursuit is her life we know that
her life is hanging in the balance if
she fails at achieving that goal
she's going to die um the sacrifices
that she makes
in pursuit of that goal include um
spending less time with her son so we
know that this
saving her life is very important to her
not only
to save her life right life and death
but also because she doesn't she's a
single mom and she doesn't want to leave
her son
an orphan right but so she's sacrificing
time with him
time that could make her feel like a
good mom
attentive mom but she has to make that
sacrifice in order to pursue the goal
because the goal is so important to her
because the stakes are so big does that
kind of make sense it does okay
what do you think 99 of screenwriters
get wrong with their screenplays
one of the biggest things that i see as
issues in scripts that i read right so i
don't know if it's 99
of screenwriters get this wrong but i
will say it is very common
is um not building the stakes properly
so that the audience is invested so so
you know it could be an exciting story
but
we'll only go along so long with
you know somebody trying to do something
if we don't understand
why they're doing it or what it means to
them right so
um building the stakes of showing us you
know what not only what happens if they
fail to achieve this goal
but also why does that matter why is it
so important to them
um what does that mean to them
internally sort of all of those
questions are really what get us
emotionally invested right
so if we look at the movie bridesmaids
again um
the you know her goal is to be your best
friends made of honor what's at stake is
externally is her friendship we know
that her the friendship is kind of the
last good thing she has in her life
and um if she fails at being her
best friends if she fails at pulling off
this sort of like made of honor duty for
her best friend
on her most important day right that
their friendship is going to suffer so
that's what's at stake for her
however there's also a deeper internal
thing that that means
for the protagonist she her friendship
being the last
best sorry the last good thing that she
has in her life
speaks to her self-worth she has
essentially failed
in all other aspects of her life if she
fails at this she will have proven she's
not a good enough friend
she can't keep up with where her friend
is sort of going in her life right like
her friend is kind of
moving into this rich people's world and
adult world she's getting married she's
going to have a real like
you know house and husband and all this
stuff
so it's it all of that kind of speaks to
how annie the
kristin wig character feels about
herself if she fails at doing this
it will say something about her as a
person so
that you know setting up those like or
helping the under
the audience understand the deeper
meaning behind the stakes
it's great to have external concrete
stakes that we can see
because we're watching movies right but
helping the audience understand what it
really means
and why that meaning is so important to
the character i would say
that's one of the biggest things that
people miss when they're writing scripts
so you think maybe a lot of people might
have a clear goal
for their character and and that we see
that this character
wants it at all cost but we're not
seeing the little
sub things in their lives that will
suffer yeah if they don't get it
and all the things they have to
sacrifice or do or compromise
yeah i think it's it's um a lot of
people
understand that they need stakes in
their story they're you know
there needs to be some consequence for
failure right otherwise why is this
character doing this thing
um but i think the thing that a lot of
people miss
is is tying those stakes to
a deeper meaning so it's not just an
external thing it's not just because
when you're dealing with things that
aren't life and death it's
it's even more important to go into the
the the why behind it right that letting
us know
why does this and why does it matter who
cares if this character
fails uh at being a maid of honor who
cares right
that those external stakes we get them
and we see them
but they only get us emotionally
invested because we understand what they
mean
to the protagonist so that's the part
you know and that's the hard thing
to do which is probably why it's missed
a lot so
right i'm thinking of let's say lady
bird you talked about that so
if the main character she grew up i
think in sacramento
and but she felt like she grew up on the
wrong side of the tracks where all her
friends
maybe were a little more affluent and
she's always wanted to kind of prove
that she belonged in that world kind of
thing yeah and so
even though she has this like loving
family at home yeah it's
to her she just wants to be accepted in
the friendship world
so i think if i remember right her her
goal in that movie
like the the actual sort of external
goal that we're kind of like hanging the
you know the plot on like the structure
of the movie i think it was getting
accepted into an east coast school was
that right
right and then the mom's like you're
just going to go to community college
yeah
right and so so if we just say that's
her goal and i can't remember for sure
if this is exactly the way the movie was
structured but
if we say that's her goal it's like
she's she's pursuing getting accepted to
an east coast school
if she fails at getting accepted to an
east coast school she's gonna have to go
to sacramento state and prove her mom
right
right so that's kind of the external
stakes but what does that mean to her
internally i would say it would to her
going off of what you said it would
prove that she isn't as good as those
kids that she wants to fit in with or
maybe that she'll never be
anything more than you know the
surroundings that she
grew up in right which for most of the
movies she sees as not good enough
i think by the end she comes around to
sort of appreciating the upbringing she
had and
where she came from right but um but for
most of the movie
she feels like this is very this is a
very important goal to her because
she's trying to leave this behind and if
she can't do that
it will basically prove that she fits in
here at this place that she doesn't
think is good enough
you know right right okay yeah and i
think actually that's what a lot of
people related to
because it's that internal feeling of
like
i think a lot of people can relate to
that like wanting to wanting to sort of
get out of the town that you were raised
in
right and then maybe maybe relating even
to the eventual
feeling of like oh it wasn't so bad i
actually kind of appreciate that
right or or growing up in a town where
there's like
a divide in
[Music]
access to different things and and
wanting to go with the kids that the
cool kids that seemed like they had
everything and they had the big house
and
and her feeling like she was less than
because her parents even though
hard-working or i know the dad was out
of work for a while but
you know especially the mom you know was
a nurse or whatever and
feeling like what wasn't glamorous
enough yeah and she wanted to be a new
yeah she wanted to be this other person
right and
um i think failing at that goal kind of
kind of what was
internally at stake for her was proving
that she couldn't be that other person
she couldn't
be more than i guess she was born into
you know
right okay yeah how does a writer create
an emotional
core for their story where the audience
will relate
and go on the journey and feel the ups
and downs
um well i usually talk about the
emotional core
as being sort of a combination of four
components actually five so there's
another fifth
stealth element here um so the four that
i think um
are involved are the things that
basically the character has to
prioritize
over the course of the story and the way
they
prioritize those things sort of the
change in their priorities
shows us the effect that the plot events
have had on them if that makes sense
so they start out um
in a status quo so they have a we're
just going to get real technical with it
so they start out with an inner drive so
some some sort of inner motivation
that's um causing them to uh
that sort of i take that back that's
that's motivating their actions in life
right
i'll use my favorite example so in die
hard um
john mclean shows up on page one wanting
to fix his marriage that's what's
driving him internally so
we know that he has come to la he wants
to
bring his wife back to new york their
marriage has been
sort of struggling whatever so we know
that that's what's driving him
internally
um he also has a misbehavior so some
people call this a character flaw
um i like to call it a misbehavior
because
uh i don't think it has to be
objectively negative
right so it's a it's a behavior that
isn't serving them
as well as they think it is or it's some
strategy that they're using
in order to pursue that inner motivation
right so he shows up on page one wanting
to
um fix his marriage and the strategy
that he's using for that
is by being macho and uncompromising
right so he's basically a caveman when
he shows up he's like
i'm gonna take my wife and drag her back
to new york with me right
that's kind of his attitude when he
shows up so those are the first two
elements that's kind of the character
status quo right what's motivating them
internally
and the the way they're going about
getting it which is really their
defining characteristic it's their
misbehavior right
and then the other two things are the
stakes and and the goal and we've
already talked about those so you know
what those are very well
so those four things are in play
um they're they're put in play basically
in the setup of your story right so he
shows up on page one wanting to
fix his marriage the way he's going
about it is by being macho and
uncompromising uh over the course of act
one
terrorists show up and he forms the
story goal of needing to save those
hostages
from the terrorists right and one of the
hostages is his wife
so that's his story goal what's at stake
the lives of the hostages
including his wife right he really wants
to save his wife's life
obviously because that goes to fixing
his marriage
so those four things these are his
priorities when we have completed our
setup
as we watch the movie uh and his pursuit
of that goal and all of the things that
are
happening to him as he pursues the goal
all of the complications and obstacles
and that main force of antagonism
those things and his um the the
plot events that he's um encountering
are forcing him to re-prioritize
now die hard is is a slightly
rare example because um he he isn't
necessarily forced to reprioritize by
his interaction with the terrorists
but because he goes through this whole
experience of
potentially losing his wife right she
might die he might die
they may never be able to get back
together and make it work right
because that's hanging in the balance he
is forced to have sort of this like
come to jesus moment where he's like i
have been doing things wrong
he says to his cop buddy on the outside
like if i ever get out of here or if i
don't get out of here
tell my wife that i was wrong or that i
should have done things differently or
something like that i can't remember the
exact dialogue but
he has that moment where he admits that
he has been
going about things the wrong way because
he thought he knew the right way he
didn't give her enough credit
right so he continues through the rest
of the plot and then by the end of the
movie we see how he has prioritized
those four things so he
has managed to save the hostages so he's
accomplished the goal
he has protected his stakes because he
has saved the lives of those hostages
including his wife
um he is going to be able to fix his
marriage we get the sense right because
his wife
and he have that like moment at the end
where they're working together
right and then his uh his misbehavior
is the last thing that's that's left
that could potentially change and so
by the end of the movie this may be my
interpretation but i think that he has
come to realize that he cannot
treat his wife like he's a caveman and
he's macho and uncompromising anymore he
has to take her needs into account too
her input she's a smart lady she's
clearly like had this whole career that
she didn't need him for right so they're
more equals than he thought he doesn't
have to protect her all the time
he can let her be a part of their
marriage they can be a partnership
so he has re he has reprioritized those
four
things and really what i mean by that is
he's he's sort of like
you know let go a little bit of the
machoness in order to
get the other things saving his marriage
you know
um uh saving the hostages um
basically that's it saving the hostages
and protecting their lives right so
the way he re-prioritizes those things
shows us
the uh emotional arc and the character
arc right
now we know how he's changed we know
that he started out thinking he had to
be this macho protector
and by the end he knows that he can
actually allow his wife
to be a real partner in their marriage
and they can work together
and right off into the sunset together
does that make sense yes it does
wow that's excellent i don't even
remember what my initial question was
because i'm like
still i'm thinking about the movie and
right right and how he softens a little
bit has a little more humor to it right
right and die hard is a big action movie
so it's not like he's gonna have this
you know profound like internal change
where he goes from being
macho to being just a pussycat who's you
know not gonna stand up to anyone it's
not gonna be that kind of like 180
change
but we do see that he has re-prioritized
those four things and that's what the
question was which
was about the emotional core so that's
what the emotional core
it's just a term that i use to sort of
encapsulate the
character arc and the emotional journey
and kind of the um the take away message
of the theme
all in one because that's really when we
see that character go through this
experience and have this particular
change or adjustment in attitude that
tells us that gives us the lesson of the
theme it tells us what's important
uh that we need to know about how to
live a better life or be a better person
or whatever
and if we look at the stakes too it's
not just the terrorists but then
the aren't they like in a very high
point on the building
yeah just be like the arco building or
whatever the highest one in l.a yeah and
so
there's the stakes of that how are they
going to
access this level and there's different
you know they're going the stairwells
and things like that so that's
the nakatomi building oh okay sorry no
in the movie in the movie it's the
knocking challenge
okay right okay um in it's in century
city um
but yeah so the stakes well so the
stakes are really the
the life of the hostages right including
john mclean's wife so that's that's what
he's trying to save and then he's
he we talked about um stakes and
sacrifice he is sacrificing his own
safety
in order to protect those stakes right
which is
you know again story nerd stuff but
valuable to think about because it's
like
if he was going to risk his life to
get his wife out of a parking ticket
we'd be like that's
i'm not i'm not on board with the story
people would check out they'd stop
reading
stop watching the movie or whatever
right so the the stakes and the
sacrifice have to really balance we have
to understand
how how they warrant each other
essentially
you know well you see a story like it's
like it's a bad thing or you have to
apologize
wouldn't doesn't someone have to really
be a story nerd
to write well because if you're too cool
for story
then you're going to ignore a lot of the
details
and a lot of this parts of this engine
correct yeah well i mean
thank you for saying that no i i think
so
um so i like
thinking about kind of the the theory of
how
you know how stories work and all the
parts and i
that's my favorite thing that's why i do
what i do
but i actually think that um i mean yes
is it valuable for writers to understand
definitely
um i don't think everyone is as nerdy
about it as i am
but so and and i don't think that's a
problem uh i do think
a lot of writers come at their stories
sort of instinctively and intuitively
and you know we all have kind of that
sense of a story right like we all
understand beginning middle and end
and um we've had that ingrained in us
since we're kids and so
i think i think a lot of writers don't
need to understand kind of the minutia
of all of this stuff as much as as much
as um i enjoy talking about it
um because they come at their stories
instinctively and they just have a story
they want to tell and
it can you know they can get it on the
page without
thinking about stakes or you know
sacrifice maybe
um on the first pass right but where i
where i do think it will come in handy
is if um
if you are struggling to make a story
work or
several screenplays work right if you're
kind of running into the same problems
over and over
then i think it's super valuable to look
at what is it that i
am instinctively not getting right
where is that thing happening that's
that's not allowing my story to work as
well as it could
uh and then that's maybe the the part of
the story nerd
canon to dive into um just figuring out
like
what is the thing that uh i'm not
automatically bringing to the page
and and you know sort of like
understanding that part of it a little
bit better and maybe honing those skills
so then the story nerd can take the
rubik's cube apart
and have all the pieces down and put it
back together but they don't
someone can still configure the the cube
just to have it all the same colors on
the outside
and they're still going to be a good
rubik's cube solver right okay so they
don't have to necessarily
pull every little plastic piece out yeah
i mean i i think that's a really good
analogy
that i had never thought of um but yeah
i think that's true like i really like
and i do think of it in in terms of like
being a mechanic i really like being
able to totally disassemble a story and
look at each little part and go oh i see
what you did there and i see what you
did there
and i see how you're making all of these
things work together and that's really
cool
and here's the one thing that's that's
knocking
right or that's like i'm actually not a
car person but here's the one thing that
is making that funny noise so let's look
at that and maybe
talk about why um the
choice that you made isn't as strong as
it could be or is getting in the way of
something else or whatever it is right
so um so i like to be a story nerd
because i
i just enjoy it um and i think that i
can
sometimes i can help other people
understand
the one little area that they might not
be fully understanding
by bringing that to them but i don't
think every writer needs to be able to
you know understand every single every
single thing that we've talked about
today would you advise your students to
start a screenplay
without an outline and just start
writing don't worry about structure
so um i think that you should do
whatever works for you
and um you know not everyone likes to
write with an outline
different processes work for different
people so i think whatever works for you
is great
however i do think that a lot of writers
you know especially if they're just
learning the craft they get stuck
without an outline and so for that
reason
i do teach an outlining class because i
think that
having a strong outline can really help
you make it all the way through to your
finished
first draft right which is which is
where you're going to learn the most it
doesn't
you don't learn as much by starting 10
screenplays as you do by finishing
one screenplay so i do think
having an outline can really help you
make it through the process which is why
i advise doing it if you
don't already have a process that works
for you um
i also think that you know the writing
process
is a lot of work and you end up doing
the same amount of work regardless
so to me it's preferable to do the heavy
lifting up front
figure out all of the stuff make all the
mistakes you're going to make with
plotting
in the outlining phase so that you don't
have to
spend all that time writing the script
and then work with
100 pages you're working with five pages
of an outline when you're trying to
rearrange things figure out why your
structure's not working
figure it you know figure out how to
escalate things or whatever it is that
you're doing do you ever see some of the
students
do an outline and realize i don't like
my story
yes i think that that can happen
um but i think it's usually temporary so
um part of the fun of outlining
i think is is actually that you are
doing a lot of the
heavy lifting right so you're thinking
through what are all the details
how is this you know how's the plot
gonna progress what's the character arc
what are the relationships like what are
the
you know big set pieces what are the
obstacles all that good stuff so you're
actually doing a lot of the fun
imagining and story creation stuff in
the outlining phase
so i think for that reason it doesn't
happen very often where somebody
outlines
a whole story and then decides they
don't like it enough to write it
um i think that when that does happen
a lot of times the problem isn't
actually in
having gotten through the outline itself
the problem is really in the concept
so now that they've seen what this
concept
looks like in you know fully fleshed out
into a whole story
then they go oh that wasn't you know i
thought there was something interesting
there
but now it it just it's not delivering
like the entertainment value that i
wanted or whatever
whatever they don't like about it so i
think um if you get to a full outline
and at that point you're feeling
disappointed in your story it might have
something to do with
that initial you know premise that you
came up with
getting a script to someone for fresh
eyes how does a writer know that they're
getting their script to the right person
what if they're getting it to a friend
who's only going to tell them great
things what they want to hear
and then conversely what if they get it
to someone who the writer views is
overly critical
but actually that's the best person to
give it to
yeah i mean you're asking the eternal
question of like
no no it's good um because that is
really confusing right if you've
if you've gone through the whole
struggle of finishing your screenplay
the next question is like who
who do i give it to who reads it um
so i don't necessarily think you think
it's a bad thing if you want to give
your script to somebody who's going to
give you praise i think that that's okay
that can make you feel good right and
kind of get you over the hump of like
okay now i need to rewrite it
um but i wouldn't rely solely on all
positive reviews um i think the things
to think about maybe when you're having
people read your script for the purpose
of giving you
feedback or notes that you're going to
implement
into your you know into your next draft
um think about
where this person is coming from in
terms of experience how many scripts
they read
um you know because reading a script is
a whole it's a whole
thing that you have to get used to right
like if my mom read a script tomorrow
she would not know what to make of it
she wouldn't
have any idea sort of how to consume a
story in this
medium so someone who has a lot of
experience reading scripts they're just
going to have a better sense of
what's working and not working just
right off the bat i think
i would be careful that you're not
giving it to someone who
um who doesn't have your best interests
right
which can sometimes be the danger of
writer's groups um
not everyone you want to make sure the
person who's reading your script
is wants to help you get that script
where
you want it to be not where they they
want it to be unless you're
unless you're writing for a producer so
so then you know
then you're going to do what they're
what they want you to do but um
no but if you're just writing a spec and
you're trying to get feedback on it to
improve
the script um you want to make sure that
the people reading it
have experience so that they can
understand how to process
a story in a script and then also that
they um
they want to help you achieve your goal
with the script
versus turning it into what they think
it should be
i think those are probably the two main
things i would say to look out for
and experience doesn't necessarily
equate with
having your best interests yeah okay
that's definitely true
and that's really sounds like something
that it's going to be case by case
you're just not going to know yeah i
mean
yeah i guess that is
you know hopefully if you're giving to
if you're giving your script to somebody
for a friendly read so it's not
a service that you're paying for or
something like that right if it's just
you know your
friend that you met in writing class and
you want to get notes from them
um hopefully you know them well enough
that you can gauge what kind of
where they're coming from with their
notes right are they going to help you
try to get where you want to be
and if you don't know that about them
and you give them your script anyway
hopefully you understand the difference
between
notes that are helping you and notes
that are taking you totally away from
your original
vision right and that's a good thing to
think about too
is um distinguishing between those
types of nodes or being able to you have
to be able to
take a note in sort of evaluate
its usefulness to you and then not get
your feelings hurt
and decide decide if you're going to
implement it or not
right and then just this is me saying
this not not you but
also maybe be careful of people too
eager to take a look at your stuff
and hey let me actually why don't you
email me that
because sometimes then you can see that
wow and then you get this feedback and
it's totally
it's it's not only helpful it's
discouraging so sometimes there's like
this
this sheep in or what is it a wolf in
sheep's clothing and you don't totally
realize it
so i think it's just developing a
rapport with someone because you'll
you'll quickly see that yeah and also
another
sort of good you know yardstick to
measure whether you want somebody to
read
um is just talking about them about
movies in general or other screenplays
right because you can gauge somebody's
taste you can gauge whether you agree
with them on
the things that because everyone has
opinions about movies they've seen like
oh the ending of that was terrible
or whatever if you disagree with
everything that they're saying
maybe that's not a person you want to
read your script because clearly you
have a difference in
you know point of view when it comes to
like what makes a good story or what
makes a story work
so i'd say that's something that you can
you know sort of
keep in the back of your mind as a way
to gauge whether someone should read
your material
or not yeah so it sounds like story
mechanics take a long time
to fine-tune and also finding that
person for feedback
takes this the same yeah um and also
another thing you could do is
trade reads right because if you if you
have someone who is
invested in getting good feedback from
you or useful feedback
and um not getting their feelings hurt
then you'll probably have a little bit
more of an even trade there too
right that's a good point yeah
what are your top three screenwriting
rules top three screenwriting rules well
um i mean very broadly don't bore the
reader
don't confuse the reader and um
make me feel something yeah those are
good yeah
i mean i know those are pretty pretty
broad ones but really that's what you're
looking for when you read a script
don't bore me what did i say don't
confuse me and
make me feel something okay yeah okay
that's not confusion or boredom yeah
yes exactly okay um for the first script
that you see from someone
how often are all those boxes checked
not very often well i'll take that back
especially a first draft right so
in your first draft there's almost
always going to be something and this
isn't just for new writers this is for
everybody in your first draft there's
almost always going to be something
that could be you know ramped up so that
i'm not bored
or something that could be clarified so
that i understand
what's happening or what i'm watching or
why i'm watching it um
and the the feeling thing i think is the
is probably the hardest one to get um so
that's probably the one that's missing
the most often
what's your favorite chapter of saved
cat
oh that's a good question um let's see
i'm gonna go with chapter four
no kidding no so chapter four
is where he breaks down the 15 beats on
the save the cat beat sheet
um the only reason i know that is
because we use that that particular
chapter in the workshop so um but i do
like that one that was the one the first
time
i read it that really you know i mean
and i think a lot of people have this
reaction they read it and they go
oh this feels so easy this feels like
i understand the way a story works even
if i thought i understood it before
now i feel like i could articulate it
you know
he's sort of like putting into words
something that we all kind of
sense um but maybe haven't been able to
talk about you know
and you teach some of the save the cat
the
writing through your own workshop or
through the save the cat
just through save the cat yeah so i
actually teach the la workshops for save
the cat that are
weekend workshops so it's a two-day
thing yeah okay where could someone find
out more about uh on the save the cat
website
oh great okay what type of screenplays
should a new writer focus on writing
or not focus on writing that's a good
question so
i think again you can you can write
whatever
you want to write but um i think you're
setting yourself up for success if you
are sort of still in that
beginning learning curve if you start
out with a more straightforward story
so one that has a very clear protagonist
a
you know a nice clear external story
goal for them to pursue with like a
clear
end point so that we know when they've
won or lost
a good clear external force of
antagonism right because you're going to
make your job easier if you can
have external things that you can put on
screen
and good clear stakes too so i think if
you have
all of those all of those foundational
pieces
in a very um sort of straightforward way
in your story
that's going to be an easier story for
you to sort of learn on it's
it's you know think of it as a learning
exercise to figure out
how to put a screenplay together you're
just going to make that
learning curve a little bit easier to
handle
if you are working with those elements
that are more straightforward
so as great as crash and the hours are
don't don't start maybe with something
like that where it's like different
vignettes or yeah
different stories that yeah i would say
those would be tough to start on because
if you don't totally
i guess it's if you don't totally have
like that rhythm
of story right like the the pace and
knowing
when things need to happen in order to
keep our interest or
get us emotionally invested or keep us
engaged you know all that stuff
um if you haven't really like
internalized that yet
then it's hard to sort of um
put a story together using different
vignettes or story lines or whatever
that's going to
function the right way that's going to
hit all of those things that we need
in order to get invested and stay
invested in the story
um because you know that's like those
are sort of tricky tricky stories to
lay out and if you're dealing with a
more straightforward story
you're going to have an easier time sort
of figuring out like okay so i just have
to focus on this one protagonist how can
i get my audience to care about him
what is it about his story goal that's
so meaningful to him and how can i show
that to the audience
it's sort of like um i don't know i
guess
um don't have a good example for you
i was gonna say it's it's um it's just a
very basic
you know i guess learning the the sort
of um
basic cooking skills before you start
you know trying to
make the julia child french you know
whatever repertoire of food so
right right don't make a bouillabaisse
before you can do scrambled eggs
there you go there you go okay
what about genre should people stick
with one genre in the beginning
uh when they're learning um i i think
you should write whatever you want to
write um i mean genre-wise in terms of
like
when you are writing screenplays that um
because you know let's face it like your
first screenplay probably isn't going to
be great and probably isn't going to be
the one that you show to a bunch of
people
so if you want to write one horror and
then see how you do with a rom-com
great i think you're again you're
learning
so much just by finishing those scripts
um you're learning how to put a story
together how to convey that story in a
screenplay
if you're working in different genres
you're also sort of learning
how to you know the the intricacies of
different genres and what we expect from
them and how those work
so i think those are all great learning
experiences
uh if you're at the point where you're
trying to sort of make a career
then i think it's useful to think about
your portfolio that you're representing
to people
right or presenting to people um and
in in terms of your portfolio you want
that to speak
uh to who you are as a writer and so
then it's probably useful to think about
you know working in one niche or one
genre
um but again you don't have you don't
have to pigeon your
pigeon hole yourself either i have uh
several writers that i work with who
you know started in one genre and then
sort of transitioned into other genres
when they
when they wanted to or when they decided
that that was going to be better for
their careers
um other writers i know who are working
writers they
you know they write a rom-com for
netflix and then they write a horror
movie for
an indie producer and it works out fine
for them too